وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه قالت ان حامله
الطائرات التابعه للبحريه الصينيه
لينك وصلت المزيد من نشاطها العسكري في
المحيط الهادئ وتوجهت جنوبا الى غرب جزيره
غوام التي تضم اكبر مركز للجيش الامريكي
في المحيط الهادئ بين يومين الثالث
والعشرين والخامس والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري
الخارجيه الصينيه الولايات المتحده الى
الالتزام بالسياسه الصين الواحده وعدم
تحريض تايوان على الاستقلال كما دعتها
للابتعاد عن الثمانيه
بجد اخرى قلى الجيش الامريكي الى طائره
عسكريه صينيه نفذت في الحادي والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري مناوره غير امنه في بحر جنوب
الصين قرب طائره عسكريه امريكيه مما الطرق
اذاها الى المراوغه لتفادي الاصطدام بين
الطائرتين واوضح الجيش الامريكيه ان
الطائره الصينيه حلقت على بعد نحو سته
امتار من الطائره الامريكيه
للقاء المزيد من الضوء على هذه التطورات
من الجانبين معنى مدير مكتبنا ناصر عبد
الحق ومن واشنطن مراسلنا محمد العلمي
بدايه معك ناصر من بيجين تفضل دعنا في
سوره وجهه النظر
والتصور الصيني لمجره
نعم ليلى التطور الصيني هو في وصول حامله
الطائرات الصينيه اليومين والقطع البحريه
المرافقه لها الى منطقه
قباله جزيره تيجوان التي عليها واحده من
اكبر القواعد الامريكيه في المحيط الهادئ
حيث كانت الصين قد بدات هذه المناورات
البحريه في ال 22 من الشهر الجاري واليوم
اعلنت هيئه الاركان
وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه عن الاقتراب هذه
القطعه البحريه الصينيه من جزيره اجوان
كانت الصين خلال العقود الماضيه تفقر الى
اصول بحري قادر على تهديد اعدائها كما
يقول الصينيون في الخارج لكنها خلال العقد
الاخير قامت بتطوير قطاعها البحريه وغدت
تمتلك الان حاملين طائرات هما اليومين وهي
الاولى والتي كانت قد اشترتها من اوكرانيا
وكانت من انتاج الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
وقامت الصين بتطويرها وبعد ذلك قامت الصين
بانتاج حامله الطائرات التاليه والتي تدعى
شاندونج بامكانتها الخاصه والان في سدد
همم
الانتهاء من صناعه حامله الطائرات الثالثه
فوجان والتي يقول المراقبون عنها بانها
الاكثر تطورا كما ان هناك همم
150 سفينه بحريه الان تمتلكها الصين مقابل
390 او 393 قطعه بحريه امريكيه وبالتالي
الصين يعني خلال السنوات الاخيره تظهر
تقدما في مجال قوتها همم البحريه كل هذه
التطورات قال مراقبون ومحللون
سيل على موقع صحيفه جلوبال تايمز الناطقه
باسم الحزب الشيوعي الصيني بانك جميع هذه
المناورات همم تاتي في اطار دفاع الصين عن
مصالحها في المنطقه وجاء المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه اليوم ليؤكد على
هذا
الموضوع حيث قال او حتى الولايات المتحده
على التوقف عن دعم تايوان عسكريا
والالتزام
بمبادئ العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه
والالتزام بالمبادئ همم الثلاثه المشتركه
او المعلنه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
وقال ايضا ان الصين ستكون او ست- يعني
ستكون دائما تدافع عن مصالحها في حزم
لنستمع الى ما قاله المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الصيني
منديله اهي
الاسلحه الامريكيه لمنطقه تايوان الصينيه
تحث الصين الولايات المتحده على الالتزام
بمبدا صيني واحده وبنود البيانات الثلاثه
المشتركه للصين والولايات المتحده والعمل
الجاد على التعهد الذي قطعته لقياده
الامريكيه بعدم دعم استقلال تايوان ووقفه
مبيعات الاسلحه والتواصل العسكري مع
تايوان والتوقف عن خلق التوترات جديده عبر
مضيقي تايوان ستتخذ الصين اجراءات قويه
لحمايه سيادتها ومصالحها الامنيه بحزم
اذا ناصر وضعنا في سوره الموقف الصيني
ماذا عن الموقف الامريكي محمد تفضل
حتى الان لم يصدر اي رد فعل رسمي امريكي
حول تحرك حامل الطائرات الصينيه لكن واضح
ليلى ان البلدين وعلى الرغم من
الاعرابي عن حرشه ما خلالنا او على هامش
قمه العشرين في بالي الاندونيسيه الشهر
الماضي على الحرص على عدم تطور التنافس
بينهما الى مواجهه عنيفه يبدو ان هما يعني
لم يستطيع حتى الان الوضع خارطه الطريق
للحين ولا دون وقوع ذلك ويبدو ان منطقه
المحيط لهذه الان همم انضمت الى تايوان
همم احدى بؤر التوتر المحتمله بين البلدين
خاصه ان الولايات المتحده تعتبر الجزر
المتناطره في المحيط كان دفاعا طبيعيه همم
استراتيجي بين الولايات المتحده واسيا
وايضا بنسبه لحلفائها في المنطقه همم من
اليابان الى نيوزيلندا الى استراليا همم
ايضا على القرار ال ال في القرار
الافريقيه ايضا مؤخرا عقدت قمه امريكيه
افريقيه وعلى الرغم من عدم الاشاره الى
الصين لكن واضح ان الهدف كان هو تحجيم
الدور المتزايد للصين في القاره الافريقيه
وبالتالي يبدو ان صفحه جديده في العلاقات
الدوليه ونسخه جديده من حرب بارده كل هذا
يتم وسط اجماعي الحزبين الرئيس الجمهوري
السابق
رسوم الجمركيه على الصين الديمقراطيه ايضا
حافظ عليها
ميزانيه الدفاع عن العام القادم ارتفعت
بشكل كبير على الر من انها الاعلى على
مستوى العالمي
والرساله واضحه انها موجهه الى بيجين
بالاضافه الى تنصيصها على تصليح همم
تايوان وبالتالي يبدو ان خارطه الطريق غير
موجوده حتى الان كما كان الشائم مع
الاتحاد السوفياتي في الماضي
وهناك الان زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكان سوني بلانكا الى بيجين مطلع
العام القادم ربما من اجل وضعي معالم طريق
تحول دون مواجهه عنيفه اما عن قصد او عن
طارق الخطا شكرا جزيلا محمد العالمي من
واشنطن وناصر عبد الحق من بيجين على كل
هذه التفاصيل شكرا